bonsoir à nouveau 78 sur TVfil 78 une
nouvelle heure pour faire le tour
complet de l'actualité locale en direct
de 18 à 19H premierre invité de ce 19
février Robert Cadalbert bonsoir bonsoir
le président PS de la communauté
d'agglomération de Saint-Quentin en
iveline avec vous nous parlerons
d'aménagement du territoire du notamment
le schéma d'aménagement de la région
Île-de-France et puis du Grand Paris
Express vous nous direz si les
orientations du gouvernement mais aussi
de la région vous conviennent répondre
en tout cas à vos attentes vous
entendrez aussi tout à l'heure le point
de vue sur ces différentes questions
d'Alain Schmitz le président UMP du
conseil général des Yvelines pour
débuter voici les titres les principaux
sujets que nous allons développer ce
soir le premier restaurant universitaire
écolo de France cela se passe sur le
campus de l'UFR des Sciences à
l'université de versaillsintquentin les
déchets alimentaires servent à produire
du compost compost ensuite réparti sur
les espaces verts de la commune de
Versailles le point sur le pôle pilote
de sécurité locale installé à aencour
son objectif mieux coordonner les
actions des services de secours et de
sécurité en y associant les savoirs
techniques et d'une cinquantaine
d'entreprises du secteur le moyen-âge
une époque parfois méconnue toujours
fascinante qui fait l'objet d'une
exposition actuellement à hencour nous
en parlerons notamment avec l'une des
responsables des Archives
départementales tout à l'heure sur ce
plateau et puis en sport du tir à l'arc
avec le championnat de division
départementale par équipe c'était à
trappe 23 équipes en compétition
Conflant saint-onorine qui rafle la mise
le meilleur club saintcontinois termine
4e il s'agit de celui de Montini le
Bretonneux et puis l'environnement il en
sera aussi question avec Valérie oribau
bonsoir Valérie nous sommes mardi c'est
le jour de la page environnement avec
vous dans une demi-heure oui et nous
mettrons les les mains dans la terre he
puisque l'hiver est bientôt fini donc
nous verrons comment réaménager son
potager pour les jours qui viennent et
ce sera avec votre invité je le disais
dans une petite vingtaine de minutes une
demi-heure pour cette page de
l'environnement nous allons également ce
soir parler du mesena je recevrai la
responsable des relations entreprises du
château de Versailles le directeur de la
Société générale régionale nous dira
aussi pourquoi il a décider d'investir
autour de l'Opéra royale tous les
détails tout à l'heure pour l'instant
focus sur ce pôle pilote de sécurité
locale installé à éencours avec pour
objectif de coordonner les actions des
services de secours et de sécurité
reportage vaer ib et le
diine police nationale municipale Pompi
et le pôle pilote de sécurité locale
deslancours ces services bientôt
travailleront de concert pour intervenir
au plus vite sur le terrain le but
gagner du temps pour sauver encore plus
de vie le PPSL est un centre pour tester
les nouvelles technologies dans le
domaine de la sécurité pour les forces
de secours les forces de police qui ont
besoin d'intervenir très rapidement
d'échanger l'information et de
comprendre ce qui se passe sur une
situation on offre les technologies qui
permettent d'y
répondre analyse de cartographie étude
des zones à risque utilisation des
réseaux sociaux en cas de crise grâce à
ces nouvelles technologies la qualité la
rapidité et la précision de
l'information s'accroit pour un meilleur
rendu sur le terrain et entre les
services c'est pas un hasard si le le
PPSL entre guillemets est à quelques
mètres du du du commissariat c'est bien
sûr pour qu'il a une synergie
d'expérimentation et bien sûr aider nos
nos nos nos équipes de police à avoir le
meilleur matériel le plus
performant une performance qui passe par
le partenariat avec plus de 50 grandes
et petites entreprises qui offrent leur
technologie et leur savoir au service de
la sécurité et des forces de
secours nous avons décidé ce soir de
revenir sur deux dossiers d'envergueure
pour les prochaines années le SDRIF et
le Grand Paris Express le Grand Paris
Express c'est ce super métro reliant la
banlieu à la banlieue un projet initié
par Nicolas Sarkozi par le précédent
gouvernement repris ensuite par François
Hollande avec certaines précautions nous
en avons parlé d'ailleurs sur ce plateau
avec ce rapport ce rapport auos anné qui
évoquéit il y a quelques semaines la
possibilité d'une réalisation par étape
et puis le report de la portion qui
concernait Saint-Quentin en Yveline
l'arbitrage du Premier ministre était
attendu pour le 15 février il est
finalement repoussé au 6 mars et puis
l'autre dossier c'est le SDRIF le schéma
d'aménagement régional là aussi les
questions de transport mais aussi de
logement et l'enjeu est important savoir
à quoi ressemblera l'île-de-fance à
l'avenir voici d'ailleurs le chiffre de
cette édition 2030 2030 c'est tout
simplement la date butoire toutes les
réalisations dudrift qui seront actcté
vont courir jusqu'en 2030 Robert
Cadalbert donc pour l'agglomération de
SaintQuentin en Yveline on va parler
tout à l'heure du du Grand Paris Express
on parle tout d'abord donc de cedrif on
va voir dans un instant les principaux
chiffres justement au-delà de tout ça
les orientations qui sont prises par
Jean je pauluchon le président PS de la
région est-ce que ça vous satisfait
est-ce que vous êtes satisfait avec les
orientations en matière de logement et
puis également de transport ce Drif sur
ces orientations on ne peut être que
d'accord quand on parle de construction
de logement quand on parle de
développement des infrastructures c'est
effectivement on peut être que d'accord
avec l'esprit de ce schéma directeur de
la région de France on va don quelques
chiffres justement pour permettre
d'étailler votre réponse sur les
différentes réalisations concernant le
transp quelques chiffres 60
nouvellesgarees 70 km de RER prolongé 75
km de tramoou également et puis en ce
qui concerne la partie du logement 70000
logements par an en Île-de-France et 30
% de logements sociaux voilà pour les
principaux chiffres l'orientation et ce
schéma sera débattu il y a une enquête
justement publique qui sera ouverte à
partir du mois de mars on a vu quelques
chiffres ça permet de conforter votre
réponse justement sur ces réalisations
de logement 70000 logements par an en
Île-de-France 30 % log c'est faisable et
même à50el ce schéma avait été adopté en
2008 voilà et effectivement il prévit
60000 l'ancien président de la
République a voulu en mettre 70000
pourquoi pas après c'est comment on les
fait et effectivement il y a deux
critères important pour construire du
logement en Île-de-France c'est les
transports et l'emploi il faut conforter
ce qui est dans le schéma c'est la
région Île-de-France un système de
multipolaire c'est pas la R - de France
uniforme par partout pareil c'est un
système multipolaire et il y a des des
pôles très différents 51 ville est un
pôle multi dans ce système multipolaire
et SaintQuentin un pôle reconnu comme l'
la plupart des villes nouvelles de la
grande couronne donc on veut et on
souhaite dans ce schéma bien renforcer
le rôle de Saint-Quentin nuvine dans
l'opération d'intérêt national Paris
saclé puisque Saint-Quentin est toute la
partie occidentale du plateau de Paris
saclé ça c'est un élément important et
pour l'élément majeur quand même de de
cerif qui est la construction de
logement le critère principal c'est on
construit le logement où il y a de
l'emploi c'était même le principe
fondamental de la création de la ville
nouvelle on fait du logement et on y met
de l'emploi c'est ce que n en avant le
Drif aujourd'hui c'est on est toujours
ce même principe aujourd'hui 5qutin
liveline dans ce dans ce schéma avec
l'ancien gouvernement nous avons établi
une convention d'équilibre emploi
habitable il est repris dans ce Drif je
sais que beaucoup s'en plaigne en disant
moi je trouve que c'est une bonne chose
à condition bien sûr que les paramètres
soient les bons paramètres comme on l'a
à peu près sur 50 alin c'est 2 m² de
logement
pour 1 m car de d'activité économique et
qu'on les on le l'utilise de façon
intelligente voilà ça c'est dans lerift
et je trouve que c'est une bonne chose
après on peut toujours discuter de la du
quantitatif du critère voilà parce que
il y a un ratio qui existe justement
entre le logement et puis l'emploi le
ratio c'est 2,8 donc on construit plus
de logement qu'il n'y a d'emploi ouai
non mais ce ratio effectivement faut en
discuter et c'est ce qu'on a fait depuis
2 ans depuis 2 ans avec le gouvernement
et l'ancien gouvernement on a mis en
place cette convention d'équilibre donc
ceux qui critiquent cet élément là je
trouve que c'est important on a pris une
délibération à l'agglomération unanime
sur ce sujetlà en rajoutant une chose on
souhaite que tous nos voisins soient
aussi dans la même configuration d'avoir
des conventions d'équilibre emploi
habitat voilà donc de ce côté emploi
habitat de faire on va faire du logement
70000 et on le fait prioritairement à
l'endroit où il y a du logement on ne
peut être que d'accord à condition que
le principe de mise en œuvre soit aussi
fait de façon intelligente comme l' fait
depuis 2 ans à 5 vous l'avez dit il y a
tout même une petite nuance dans le
soutien que vous apportez à ce drift
c'est c'est ce fameux ratio ce nombre de
logements construit par rapport au
nombre d'emplois qui existe il faut pas
construire non plus trop de logements
s'il y a pas assez d'emplois le
département des ilines a un problème
c'est qu'il a pas construit en en 20 ans
suffisamment de logement pour tous du
logement diversifié on voit bien qu' on
a un problème avec un habitat sur
l'ensemble des vges qui est très
hétérogène donc nous notre plche he et
en plus ce pche plan local de
l'habitation sur le plan local de
l'habitation on je l'ai présenté ce
matin au commission à la commission
régionale de l'habitat il a reçu un avis
très favorable puisque ça a été unanime
donc c'est un élément majeur dans ce
schéma de pouvoir continuer à loger dans
de bonnes conditions les habitants et
c'est un majeur pour l'attractivité d'un
territoire et ce PLH plan local c'est
1300 logements qui sont conruit chaque
année pendant 5 ans adopté à l'unanimité
voyez alors que l'ancien plche avait été
avait subi des recours celui-là était
adopté à l'unanimité avec 1300 donc pour
revenir au Drif c'est un élément majeur
mais il faut que toutes les pôles de la
région defance a la même volonté de
faire du logement à moment où on a de
l'emploi et ce logement on les met où
ces logement ces différentes habitations
sur C1 en Yveline puisque le PLH a reçu
cet avis favorable vous les imaginez où
ces réalisation dans le PLH c'est
indiqué exactement le nombre de
logements sur les endroits 90 % de ce
péage des 1300 logements sont
individualisés précisés en terme de
d'emplacement pour les téléspectateurs
qui n'ont pas accès à l'ensemble du
dossier peut-être citer quelques
communes quelques endroits où il
pourrait voir des logement dans les 5
ans qui qui viennent c'est vrai que on
on a des actes qui se terminent comme la
Act de la Rusta à attrape on a à
villaroi des des des une ZAC aussi de
Villarois qui continue on a certainement
des AES à créé celle des Réau qui a
démarré à îencour celle de la remise que
j'espère on
démarrera un voisin de Bretonneux ou
encore la grande opération qui se autour
des bécanes à la verrière du côté du
conseil général des ivelines concernant
cerif le président UMP alin Schmitz lui
se dit inquiet il parle d'un projet à
courte vue déséquilibré son avis est
défavorable son point de vue il le
justifie au micro de Catherine la tau
qu' on nous impose sur les 20 prochaines
années à construire beaucoup plus de
logements que nous ne construisons
encore aujourd'hui pour atteindre le
chiffre de 9000 logements par an on
vient de très loin on vient de 3000 de
3000 logements tout en ne se préoccupant
pas de la création d'emplois or l'un ne
peut pas aller avec l'autre d'autant que
la situation en terme d'emploi dans les
Yvelines est préoccupante comme elle l'
d'ailleurs dans la région Île-de-France
mais peut-être plus particulièrement
dans les ivlines et plus
particulièrement le long de la de la
aller de la scène c'est tout ce qu'on
appelle scène aval donc oui pour
continuer cette politique très offensive
en terme de construction de logement
mais sous conditions sous condition
d'avoir des emplois alors la région ne
le reconnaît pas puisqu'elle nous nous
contraint un taux de
2,8 de logement pour un emploi c'est
qu'il faudrait construire 2,8 logements
pour un emploi et en terme surtout de
déficit d'infrastructure routière et de
transport en commun or aujourd'hui la
grogne est telle de la part des usagers
c'estàd c'estàd de ceux qui vivant dans
les ivelines sont obligés de se rendre à
leur lieu de travail tous les matins
dans des conditions inadmissibles que je
ne vois pas comment un maire peut
aujourd'hui accepter de construire
encore des logements supplémentaires sur
le territoire de sa commune je vais
prendre mon bâton de pallerin pour aller
à la rencontre des maires et des
présidents de PCI euh pour leur dire de
se manifester et d'attirer l'attention
sur la région sur les l'absolue
nécessité à améliorer dans les 20
prochaines années les infrastructures
routières des infrastructures en terme
de transport en commun puisque je vous
rappelle c'est un document qui va
concerner l'avenir des franiliens et
donc des ivelinois pour les 20
prochaines années en tout état de cause
ce schéma directeur va être au moins
applicable jusqu'en 2030 donc vous voyez
l'intérêt qu'il y a aujourd'hui à se
manifester à se manifester fortement
pour porter les préoccupations qui sont
celles des habitants des zivlines et ce
drift particulièrement important on en
parle encore sur ce plateau avec Robert
Cadalbert le président de l'glomra de 50
ans nieline Alain Schmit vous a contacté
vous avez eu des échanges parce que
quand on l'écoute il l'a dit lui ne
comprend pas qu'un maire puisse
aujourd'hui accepter de mettre plus de
logement alors qu'il y a pas les
infrastructures non mais sur le logement
pour finir c'est vrai que le
développement économique des des ilines
est importante vous voyez bien à
Saint-Quentin Levin quand on parle
d'emploi et de logement je dis que le
logement est un premier facteur
d'attractivité si les entreprises
s'installent à Saint-Quentin de V par
exemple cette semaine on a posé la
première pierre de de
Mercedes c'est pas le fruit du hasard
c'est parce que l'attractivité du
territoire est
là donc on va pas jouer à ce petit jeu s
renvoyer la balle faisons du logement à
l'endroit où on peut pour
qu'effectivement rendre encore plus
attractif le territoire en terme de
développement économique c'est ce que me
demande les entreprises quand il
viennent à saint-quentinvine comment je
peux loger mes salariés mais il y a un
échange actuellement avec le président
du conseil général disait qu'il allait
rencontrer les différents responsables
Politi VO qui va prendre rendez-vous
donc on va discuter c'est très bien on
se voit mais peut-être sur le ça serait
bien qu'on se voit sur effectivement
l'implication du département et
particulièrement sur les transports
parce que c'est vrai que c'est une
affaire de de de l'État c'est une
affaire de la région mais le département
a son rôle à jouer en particulier pour
moi sur la Tangentielle ouest bon je
souhaite que cette tangential ouest sera
raccordée à 51 nivelin c'est possible à
des coûts tout à fait intéressants et
tout à fait efficace pour déplacement du
ressort du département bah le le
département a mis 100 millions d'euros
avec 100 millions de région dans un
contrat particulier pour la Tangentielle
ouest il suffit d'un tout petit peu
supplémentaire pour que cette
tangentielle l'Ouest aille jusqu'à 51
Lig voilà une belle proposition je dis
Alain Schmid venons parlons de ça et
est-ce qu'on est prêt à le faire
ensemble ça ferait un axe nord- sudud
sur les isines qui serait très important
et très utile pour limiter justement les
problèmes d'embouteillage et en passant
du côté de saint-cière l'école pour être
un peu plus compè sur ce dossier puisque
vous parlez des transport le srift
s'intéresse aussi forcément au
transports et puis il a l'autre dossier
particulièrement important aussi pour
les prochaines aines années c'est le
Grand Paris Express le gouvernement je
vous le disais tout à l'heure qui devait
rendre ses arbitrages le 15 février
dernier une date qui a été repoussée
vous allez nous dire ce que vous
attendez des décisions qui sont
attendues début mars pour l'instant ce
micro trottoir quelle nouvelle ligne de
train pour le futur et particulièrement
importante pour vous voici quelques
réponses qui est plus flexibilité au
niveau des horaires et qui est prend en
période hivernale qui a plus de de train
à la disposition des étudiants une
petite buvette dans le train
voilà je pense que il faudrait plus de
ligne afin que ça soit accessible à tout
le monde plus de sécurité que la police
ferroviaire soit un peu plus présente
pas seulement le soir mais aussi la
journée accès plus direct pour aller à
Orly par exemple voilà sur 51 c'est pas
pas trop mal
desservi maintenant c'est vrai qu'il y a
des secteurs dans la région parisienne
qui le sont très mal pour Le Rest je
crois qu'il y a beaucoup de progrès à
faire au-delà des aménagement de confort
pardon il a été mentionné le cas d'un r
par exemple c'est ça fait partie des
priorités vous imaginez comment les
lignes de transport à l'avenir on peut
pas découper le système c'est vrai qu'on
parle beaucoup du du système du Grand
Paris bon mais heureusement il y a des
infrastructures la ligne cdrr elle
existe même si elle fonctionne pas
suffisamment bien la ligne pour
monparnas existe donc dans la région
î-defrance il y a tout ce système qui
marche avant d' créer d'autres il faut
améliorer ce qui existe déjà ben il faut
faire les deux parce que si on en fait
qui sont pas interconnectés par exemple
c'est vrai que j'ai entendu parler dans
le rapport aux anné qu'on allit arrêté
dans la première phase la ligne verte à
sa clé c'est une aberration si on veut
Lig en on la voit cette ligne verte à
l'image der il faut qu'elle aille
jusqu'à 51 iveline c'est une évidence si
on veut que le plateau de satelet soit
desservi directement depuis la défense
depuis et je parlais tout à l'heure de
la Tangentielle ouest c'est important
que cette tangentielle ouest qui peut
venir de serg Pontoise de Saint-Germain
d'cher et qui arrive à saincir va venir
en cul de sac à sacir raccordonsla à
5antine voilà il y a plein d'opérations
de ce typel sur les infrastructures qui
sont intelligentes efficaces c'est ce
que je demande au gouvernement j'ai
rencontré effectivement les conseillers
des des ministres concernés pour avancer
dans ce sens-là et en particulier que
cette fameuse ligne verte desserve
jusqu'à 5vg pour qu'elle soit efficace
ça c'est le premier point mais on voyait
dans dans dans les votre reportage les
gens ce qui inessent c'est demain
qu'est-ce qui se passe et en même temps
que l'on se bat pour ces infrastructure
à 10 20 ans on se bat aussi au quotidien
c'est pour ça qu'on a rénové les gares
qui sont en cours de de dé finition de
rénovation mais aussi on se bain par
exemple les TER il s'arrête à Versailles
il s'arrête pas à 50 ans en evveline
pourquoi le TER ne s'arrêterait pas à
Saint-Quentin livvin pourquoi des lignes
partent de Versailles du du RC et
partent pas de saint-quentinin le matin
on a plein de possibilités d'améliorer
au quotidien tout de suite sans attendre
10 ans 20 ans qu'on ait les grandes
infrastructures on peut améliorer le le
quotidiens des habitants pour les
transports en commun c'est notre
priorité à nous c'est pour ça qu'on fait
lesgard c'est pour ça qu'on on développe
le réseau de 51n de bus mais en même
temps on est cohérent on essaie de
développer en même temps des grandes
infrastructures qui est la vision de
c50tin lvin dans les 10 20 ou 30 ans qui
viennent justement si on se projette
dans les 10 20 30 prochaines années avec
ce Grand Paris Express si jamais le
gouvernement décide de de tronçonner de
faire des choix par exemple la ligne
verte que vous évoquez tout à l'heure si
elle est repoursée à 2030 par exemple
pour sa réalisation ça va pénaliser le
développement de 50 ans nieline le
développement vers sa clé aussi ce
développement il doit être
cohérent vous prenez l'exemple de ces
transports en commun en site propre ça
fait 15 ans qu'on est lancé à
saint-quanttinevin on a créé des voies
spécifiques sur l'avenue de Gérald
Lecler sur l'avenue de l'Europe à
yancour pour aller jusqu'à saqutin
Eveline de sa-quanttin Eveline à Massie
donc à l'époque on dit on va faire tout
ça pour passer un bus ou pas bien sûr
l'objectif c'est qu'effectivement des
bus à haute fréquence se mettent que du
tramouis et pourquoi pas un système de
transport de métro léger comme on dit
parce que et au sol parce que on nous a
dit 50 millions de kilomèt des super
métros enterrés nous on a besoin de
quelque chose qui soit adapté le mot
adapté est important c'est dans la loi
le besoin l'infrastructure de transport
doit être adapté aux besoins du
territoire au besoins des habitants et
des salariés ça veut dire vous êtes prêt
à un projet peut-être d'un peu d'
envergure peut-être un peu moindre mais
réaliser plus vite c'est ce que
préconise le président du conseil
général des zivelin également député de
première circonscription François
deierre député maire de versaill c'est
ce qu'on dit nous depuis le début depuis
2 ans avec François degier sur Guille en
cours on parle d'un d'un métro léger
avec François lamille sur la CAPS on
parle de la même chose nous ce qu' a
besoin c'est d'un transport adapté au
besoins c'est pour ça et en utilisant
tout si a l'espace de transport de bus
qu'on a réalisé depuis 15 ans à 5ant an
divine c'est vrai que faut voir l'avenir
et pour nous l'avenir c'est ce transport
en comm C propre et ce métro léger qui
devrait arriver il peut pas rester en
plein milieu du plateau de sa clé hein
pour se desservir 2000 personnes au
crise de sa clé non il faut qu'il vienne
jusqu'à 5 Line et là il a rate toute sa
place surtout s'il est interconnecté
avec la Tangentielle ouest et une
amélioration notable du RC on parlait du
SDRIF on a fait mettre c'était un
amendement qui a été porté en par par
Didier ficher pour que le RRC aille
jusqu'à coignère c'est vrai que arrêtant
à sa-quentinevine il pourit desservir la
Gard de trape la garde la verrière c'est
un plus pour les habitants sans de gros
investissements à réaliser justement
l'investissement c'est ma toute dernière
question très rapidement comment on
finance on augmente les impôts pour les
particuliers pour les entreprises le
financement pour l'instant il y a un
versement transport il y a une taxe sur
les bureaux qui est mal foutue je vous
signale que ces impôts là la taxe sur
les bureaux a été faite il y a 2 ans et
pas par le gouvernement et pas
par par pour ceux qu'on qu'on dit font
du du matraquage fiscal les matracage
fiscal ont été fait avant sur ces
bureaul aujd'hui on finance comment s'il
y a une réalisation du GR la demande que
l'on a c'est un changement de cette taxe
qui soit pas fait c'est 200 € du mètre
carré de d'activité qui soit faire et
Ben qui soit proportionnellement au prix
de sortie du mètre
carré 200 € à 550 c'est un problème pour
les investisseurs 200 € sur échang c'est
plus un problème pour les investisseurs
merci Robert Cadalbert d'être venu sur
ce plateau je redonne ces deux
informations le schéma d'aménagement
régional le calendrier enquête publique
dès le mois de mars pour une adoption en
septembre et approbation en décembre
2013 et le Grand Paris Express date
évoquée par le gouvernement pour les
arbitrages du Premier ministre ce sera
le 6 mars nous reviendrons bien sûr sur
ces différentes informations au cours de
nos prochaines éditions merci à vous on
passe à la culture première page culture
de ce soir dédié au Moyen-Âge avant de
parler tout à l'heure du mesena au
château de Versailles